It's all the podcast. The podcast is just Connor and Bryce being the best C++ buds ever. So at the risk of making this a Fortran episode... Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, Episode 6, recorded on December 26, 2020. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we talk about part 1 of our 2020 retro, but we mostly end up talking about Fortran. I've been thinking about, you know, first of all, I have to say, editing the last episode was a blast. The last, I don't know, it's bad. I don't know if this is bad, but I just like, I loved listening to the last episode, even though I was on all the episodes. But like I learned, I learned stuff last episode.
这就是整个播客。这个播客就是康纳和布莱斯成为史上最棒的C++好基友。所以，为了不让这期变成Fortran（福特兰）专场……欢迎收听ADSP播客第6期，录制于2020年12月26日。我是康纳，今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起讨论我们2020年回顾的第一部分，不过我们大部分时间都在讨论Fortran。我一直在想，你知道，首先，我必须说，剪辑上一期节目简直太爽了。上一期，我不知道，这很糟糕。我不知道这算不算糟糕，但我就是，我很喜欢听上一期节目，尽管我参与了所有节目的录制。不过，就像我学到了，我上一期学到了东西。
And also listening to my, like how excited I get. I don't think I realize, like, how excitable I am. Yes, you definitely do not realize how excitable you are. Like, I sound like a little kid. Yeah. When I was like, oh, I'll just, I'm going to reveal the big secret. Like, it's a bit silly because uh buddy you're you're you've just forced me into embarrassing you because now i gotta tell the c++ now sean parent story so for for those who do not know connor is a very big fan of sean parent who is uh one of the c++ luminaries who frequently talks about sort of elegant algorithm design, I'll say.
而且听我说话，就像我有多兴奋一样。我想我没有意识到，自己是多么容易兴奋。是的，你确实没有意识到自己有多容易兴奋。听起来就像个小屁孩。对。当时我想，哦，好吧，我要大白话了，我要透露这个惊天大秘密了。这其实有点傻，因为老兄，你，你，你刚刚逼得我让你难堪，因为现在我得跟C++圈子讲讲肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent）的故事了。所以，对于那些不知道的人来说，康纳是肖恩·帕伦特的超级粉丝，肖恩是C++领域的泰斗之一，他经常谈论某种优雅的算法设计，我这么说吧。
And the first C++ Now conference that Connor and I were at together, which was about four or five months after I met Connor. And this was the one where going into this conference, I was telling you your talk was going to win all the awards and you're like, nah, it's not going to happen. And then you won all the awards. But we're walking back from, so the conference is in Aspen, Colorado. So it's at this little hotel resort. And you often, you go into the town for dinner, for lunch, and then you walk back. And it's not like a five minute walk. It's like, you know, a 10, 20 minute walk. So you chat with people on the walk back. And it's not like a five-minute walk. It's like a 10, 20-minute walk.
康纳和我一起参加的第一场C++ Now会议，大概是在我认识康纳四五个月之后。就是那次会议，在去会场的路上，我跟你说你的演讲会赢得所有大奖，而你说：“不，不会发生这种事的。”然后你就赢得了所有大奖。我们在往回走的时候——会议是在科罗拉多州阿斯彭（Aspen）举办的。所以它在一个小度假酒店里。你经常要走到镇上去吃晚饭、午餐，然后再走回来。这不是那种五分钟的路程。大约是，你知道的，10到20分钟的步行路程。所以你在走回来的路上会和大家聊天。这可不是五分钟的路程。大概是10到20分钟的步行。
So you chat with people on the way back. And so I remember there was a group of us that was walking back. And Connor was there. And I didn't hear the full context of the conversation. But I know that the word Sean Parent was mentioned and then Connor let out a yelp that sounded like the squeal of an excited 12 year old school girl that was just his guttural reaction to the idea that Sean Parent had entered into this conversation I don't even i recall i recall all of those walks back and forth i do not recall uh squealing um but i mean that's it's not surely you surely you recall me
所以在回来的路上你可以和大家聊天。我记得当时我们有一群人正走在路上。康纳也在。我没有听清对话的全部内容。但我知道有人提到了“肖恩·帕伦特”这个词，接着康纳发出了一声尖叫，听起来就像一个激动的12岁女学生发出的尖叫，这只是他听到肖恩·帕伦特加入这场对话时的本能反应。我甚至都不，我记得所有那些来回走的路，我不记得自己曾发出过尖叫……但我的意思是，这，这不是……你肯定记得后来我……
telling this story subsequently to lots of people yes yes uh yeah i yeah well this this ties into sort of the the meta point that i was i was gonna make sort of at the beginning um of the meta point that I was going to make sort of at the beginning of the episode is that we have never – and this is true, I think, of almost every podcast I've ever listened to except for maybe a couple. At no point do podcasts ever really state like their goals. You know, I think – We have a goal? Yeah, that's the thing is We don't currently have a goal. But post-listening to last episode, I feel like implicitly we have a goal. And I think it's like two things. But we can just, what do they call it, blue sky this on the episode.
把这个故事讲给很多人听，对吧，对，呃，对，这其实关系到我一开始要说的那个元观点……我一开始要说的那个元观点的核心在于，我们从来没有——而且我认为，除了少数几个以外，我听过的几乎所有播客都是如此——在任何时候，播客都从没有真正阐明过他们的目标。你知道，我觉得——我们有目标吗？对，问题就在于，我们目前还没有目标。但在听完上一期节目之后，我觉得我们潜意识里其实有一个目标。我觉得它大概包含两点。不过我们可以在这期节目里“天马行空”地聊聊。
Or this is whatever people are listening to it. It's one, our podcast is just about two super super excited, passionate people, you know, talking about whatever they're excited about with, you know, with respect to tech. But then also. I definitely agree with that. And so that's our primary thing. But then I guess I didn't really have an expectation that I would be like actively learning things while on the podcast. And that's like, like when, specifically, when you sort of you, you know, one of the things was like, you asked, you know, do you know the one language, the ISO language that is, you know, internationalized? Like, I had no idea. And that's
或者不管听众怎么看。其一，我们的播客只是关于两个超级超级兴奋、充满激情的人，你知道，在谈论任何他们感到兴奋的技术相关话题，但除此之外……我绝对赞同这一点。所以这是我们的首要事情。但我想我真的没有料到，在录制播客的同时我还能积极地学到东西。就像，具体来说，比如当你问起，你知道，你知道哪种语言，哪种ISO语言是国际化的吗？当时我完全不知道。而这
like, it's, it's, it's not like a super, like, it's not gonna change my life. But like, I just, I love learning stuff like that. And there's been a bunch of other instances. You know, almost on every episode, actually, probably, I've learned something, you know, when we talked about the, you know, esoteric data structures, I had never heard of a ternary search tree and sort of walking through the implementation and sort of figuring that out. Like, I love learning stuff. And also, I just, I love sharing my enthusiasm for stuff. And I guess that's the thing is I guess like listening to the last episode while editing it, like I know I'm an excitable person. I just – I guess I don't – I don't – I don't really – it's not often that you're listening to your own voice while you're explaining something that you're excited about. And I just – when I was like listening to that part, was just like jesus like i need to calm down um um never calm down
就像，这并不是那种超级……不会改变我的人生。但我就是喜欢学到这样的知识。而且还有很多其他的例子。实际上，几乎在每一期节目里，我大概都学到了一些东西，比如当我们讨论那些深奥的数据结构时，我从未听说过三叉搜索树（ternary search tree），然后我们过了一遍它的实现，并把它琢磨透了。我就是喜欢学习新东西。而且，我也喜欢分享我对事物的热情。我想这就是重点，在剪辑上一期节目时，我意识到自己是个容易激动的人。我只是——我想我没有——我没有——真的——你并不经常在解释自己兴奋的事物时去聆听自己的声音。当我听到那部分时，就觉得天哪，我需要冷静点……呃……永远不要冷静，
connor never calm down i definitely i think i've definitely learned things too um yeah i mean you're you're you're you're constantly teaching me new things about apl there's There's no way I'm going to get out of this podcast without doing some APL programming. Yeah. But it's always interesting for me because you are, I think out of the two of us, you are the more inherently curious one. And it's nice because I don't have to be as curious as you. I just get these regular dumps of excitement about some new thing you've discovered. And it saves me all of the legwork of being a curious person. And so this was the thing. This all ties back.
康纳，永远不要冷静。当然，我想我也确实学到了东西……呃，我的意思是你，你，你一直在教我关于APL的新知识。我绝对不可能在不做任何APL编程的情况下录完这个播客。是的。但对我来说这总是很有趣，因为在咱们俩当中，你显然是那个天生更有好奇心的人。这挺好的，因为我不必像你那么好奇。我只会定期接收到你对某个新发现的事物爆发出的兴奋之情。这就省去了我作为好奇者所需要做的大量前期工作。所以就是这样。这一切都息息相关。
You mentioned Sean Perrin. And this all ties back to something you asked two episodes ago when we had sort of, we had our quasi debate about programming languages and how many you should learn, although very quickly it didn't, it was no longer a debate and it was just us agreeing on things. You asked at one point, like, why? Why do you like, like, it was sort of a two-part why, like, why do you like learning programming languages and why do you like what like it was sort of a two-part why like why do you like learning programming languages and why do you want to solve advent of code problem problems in apl
你提到了肖恩·帕伦特。这都追溯到你在两期节目之前问过的一个问题，当时我们进行了一场关于编程语言以及你应该学习多少种语言的半辩论，尽管很快它就不再是辩论了，而演变成了我们意见完全一致。你当时问：为什么？你为什么喜欢——这有点像一个两部分的“为什么”——你为什么喜欢学习编程语言，以及你为什么想在APL中解决“Advent of Code”的问题……
and like honestly since and i i paused and i i gave some answer about um how haskell changed the way i thought and then apl you know if haskell changed the way i thought by an order of magnitude apl it's two orders of magnitude but like i've really been trying to reflect on why do I get so excited about learning things? It's actually a very good question because you'd think after a certain period of time, you've sort of learned all the things. And one of the things that I've, upon reflecting on that question, is that I've realized, like, the experience of watching certain people give talks and certain people share their passion and enthusiasm for, like, what it is that they're talking about, for me, is like intoxicating. Like, like, I can, I can pinpoint timestamps in talks, where like, specifically, you know, one of the best moments is in a Sean Parent talk called generic programming that he gave at Pacific C++, I believe in 2018, or 19, where he is talking about, basically, like the evolution of Alexander Stepanov and how watching his evolution,
老实说，从那以后——我停顿了一下，然后回答了关于Haskell如何改变我的思维方式，然后是APL，你知道，如果说Haskell将我的思维方式改变了一个数量级，那么APL就是两个数量级——但我真的在反思，为什么我对学习新东西这么兴奋？这其实是个很好的问题，因为你可能会觉得，在经过了一定时间之后，你已经把所有东西都学遍了。在反思这个问题时，我意识到的一点是：看着某些人做演讲，看着某些人分享他们对所谈论内容的激情和热情，这种体验对我来说就像是让人陶醉。就像，我可以精确指出演讲中的时间戳，特别地，你知道，其中最好的时刻之一是在肖恩·帕伦特于2018年或2019年左右在Pacific C++上的一次名为“泛型编程”的演讲中，他在那里谈到了亚历山大·斯捷潘诺夫（Alexander Stepanov）的发展历程，以及观看他的发展历程……
like Sean Parent watching Stepanov's evolution, like how that impacted him and how that like it was inspiring for him to want to write code in like the fashion that Stepanov was learning to write code. And obviously, like we've mentioned, I'm a big Sean Parent fan, but listening to Sean talk about the way that Stepanov influenced him, for me, it's the equivalent of other people watching sports and seeing Michael Jordan in basketball jump from the free throw line and do a slam dunk.
就像Sean Parent观察Stepanov的演变一样，那种经历如何影响了他，以及那种如何像激励他以Stepanov学习编写代码的方式来编写代码的启发。很显然，正如我们所提到的，我是Sean Parent的超级粉丝，但听Sean讲述Stepanov对他的影响，对我来说，这就相当于其他人看体育比赛时，看到篮球场上的迈克尔·乔丹从罚球线起跳完成暴扣。
I used to be a huge soccer fan. And I'll clip this in the show notes. In the 2010 World Cup, I believe it was the quarterfinal. So I'm half Dutch. My last name, Hoekstra, is a Dutch name from the Netherlands. And so I'm also half Irish. But I like to say that I associate more with the dutch side because they have a better soccer team um but but the one thing about the the dutch soccer one one
我以前是个超级足球迷。我会在节目文稿里贴出这个片段。在2010年世界杯上，如果没记错的话，那是四分之一决赛。我有一半荷兰血统。我的姓氏Hoekstra是来自荷兰的荷兰姓氏。我也有一半爱尔兰血统。但我喜欢说我更有认同感的是荷兰那一面，因为他们的足球队更好嗯，不过关于荷兰足球有一点
one day uh we'll tell the story of how connor claiming to be half irish nearly got him in trouble when we were in ireland uh yeah that we'll save that for another episode. But yes, I like to watch the World Cup because it only happens once every four years and it only happens for a couple weeks, so it doesn't take up too much time. And in the quarterfinal, Uruguay was playing Netherlands and a defender, Giovanni van Bronckhorst, he scored this goal.
总有一天，我们会讲这样一个故事：康纳声称自己有一半爱尔兰血统，在我们在爱尔兰的时候差点给他惹了麻烦，是的，我们把这个留到另一期节目再说。不过是的，我喜欢看世界杯，因为它四年才举办一次，而且只持续几个星期，所以不会占用太多时间。在四分之一决赛中，乌拉圭对阵荷兰，后卫乔瓦尼·范布隆克霍斯特打进了这样一个进球。
It was just miraculous. Like it was from way outside the 18-yard box up into the top corner off of the crossbar. And this is 2010. So I'm in my second year or third year of university. And I remember I was watching this, I believe with my sister in the common room of the residence that I lived in. And I just, I went absolutely nuts like this because we went up one nothing
简直堪称奇迹。球是从18码禁区外很远的地方，直接飞进球门顶角，还击中了横梁。这是2010年。当时我上大学二年级或三年级。我记得我当时在住校的休息室里看比赛，好像是和我妹妹一起。我简直是，彻底疯狂了，因为我们以一比零领先
and Holland is the best team to have never won the World Cup. It used to be a toss up between Spain and the Netherlands, but then Spain won it in 2010 against us in the final, which is very sad. So such a large portion of our international audience is going to be in some way offended by this discussion of soccer. Yes, yes. I'm not, you know, I'm probably there's a big portion of that are offended from Europe that I'm calling it even soccer because it's football over there.
而荷兰是从未赢得过世界杯的最佳球队。过去这在西班牙和荷兰之间很难说谁会赢，但后来西班牙在2010年的决赛中击败了我们，这非常令人难过。我们的国际听众中有很大一部分会因为讨论足球而感到被冒犯。是的，是的。我不是，你知道的，欧洲可能会有很大一部分人因为我甚至叫它“soccer”而感到被冒犯，因为在那边它叫“football”。
But I just the goal was amazing. I went absolutely like crazy. And like, so the way that people get excited about sports and like moments like those where you're just seeing an individual do something amazing is like the same way I feel about like watching programming talks, which like probably sounds absolutely ridiculous. But it's, I don't know, it's awesome to see that. And, like, I think a large part of, like, my enthusiasm and passion is, like, is chasing that. Like, I now want to do, like, I want to have the effect and the impact that, like, Sean Parent has had on me on other people. And I think like learning to like when my mind is learning things and it completely is bent in like a 90 degree or 180 degree angle, that gets me excited because my thought is like, oh, wow,
但我只是觉得这个进球太棒了。我简直是疯狂了。人们对体育运动以及那些你看到一个人做出惊人举动的时刻所感到的兴奋，就跟我看编程讲座时的感觉一样，这听起来可能绝对荒谬。但是，我不知道，看到那一幕真的很棒，而且，我觉得我的热情和激情很大一部分，就是在追寻这种感觉。我现在想做的是，我想要产生Sean Parent对我有过的那种影响力和冲击力，把它带给其他人。并且我认为，当我的大脑在学习东西，并且它完全以90度或180度的角度转弯时，这会让我感到兴奋，因为我的想法是，哦，哇，
like if this is having this impact on the way I think, like this will translate into some like amazing moments where, you know, whether it's on a podcast now or in some future talk, I can, I can show people like, look at the elegance of this solution that like, I, I, at one point I had no idea was possible. Anyways, we've, we've been, or I've been rambling now for, I don't know how many minutes and we haven't even gotten to the, the topic of this podcast. But the point is, is I just, I like,
如果这对我的思维方式产生了这种影响，这将会转化为一些精彩的时刻，你知道的，无论是在现在的播客上，还是在未来的某个演讲中，我可以向人们展示，看这个解决方案的优雅之处，而这个方案，我曾经一度完全不知道它是可能的。无论如何，我们已经，或者说我已经闲聊了，我不知道是多少分钟，甚至还没切入这个播客的主题。但关键是，我只是，我喜欢，
I like the idea of the sort of the the goal of our podcast being uh to share our excitement slash enthusiasm and then also along the way for us to learn things and then hopefully the listeners learn things as well yeah i mean i definitely i definitely think we we we went into this having this implicit goal that there were we went into this with the assumption that there was some value not just to either one of us individually sharing ideas but like that our our our combined interactions like our interactions together produced this like enthusiasm and excitement that needed to be shared with the world that could inspire people um and this this actually will so this will come up so the the idea
我喜欢这样的想法，即我们播客的目标应该是，分享我们的兴奋和热情，然后在过程中让我们自己学到东西，也希望听众能学到东西。是的，我是说，我绝对，我绝对认为我们在开始做这个的时候就有一个隐含的目标，那就是我们带着这样一种假设开始的：不仅仅是我们两个中任何一个人单独分享观点有价值，而是我们的联合互动，也就是我们在一起的互动，产生了一种需要与世界分享、能够启发人们的这种热情和兴奋。嗯，这实际上会，所以这将会出现，所以这个想法
for today's podcast was sort of mentioned at the tail end of last week's was um to sort of reflect on uh 2020 and to um to you know talk about the highlights or, you know, what was the top five things? Obviously, you know, we should start this by saying, obviously, 2020 in all seriousness was a wreck of a year. And I think both, Bryce, you can disagree if you want to, but I'm sure you are in agreement that we are both in very privileged situations where we have not been impacted work-wise by any of the, what should we call them, things that have happened in 2020. Well, I think we shouldn't say that we haven't been impacted because there are people in tech who this has not been very easy for. Even there are those people who are in a very privileged position, but it may still be
今天的播客在上周节目的末尾提到过，就是反思2020年，以及讨论亮点，或者说，前五件事是什么？显然，你知道的，我们应该以这样一句话开始：显然，2020年从严肃的角度来看，真的是糟糕透顶的一年。我想布莱斯，如果你不同意的话可以反驳，但我确信你的看法和我一致，我们都处于非常优渥的处境中，我们在工作上没有受到2020年发生的任何，我们该怎么称呼它们呢，那些事情的影响。嗯，我认为我们不应该说我们没有受到影响，因为科技界有些人过得并不是很容易。甚至有些人处于非常优越的地位，但对他们来说可能仍然是
difficult for them. And we shouldn't make that seem like that's a small thing. But, you know, obviously, many of us who are in tech have it a lot better than many people in other industries. You know, my dad is a theater director. He's run small nonprofit theaters his entire career where in a bad year, he has to, like, choose not to pay himself. And this is he's retiring next year so this is going to be his second to last season and they had to basically cancel their whole season and i was just talking with him yesterday about sort of the impact that it's had on the performing art that the pandemic's had in the performing performing arts industry and um his theater was lucky you
困难的。我们不应该让这件事看起来微不足道。但是，你知道，显然，我们许多身处科技行业的人，比许多其他行业的人要好得多。你知道，我爸爸是一名戏剧导演。他的整个职业生涯都在运营小型非营利剧院，在糟糕的年景里，他不得不，比如说，选择不给自己发薪水。而且他明年就要退休了，所以这将是他的倒数第二个演出季，他们基本上不得不取消整个演出季。我昨天刚和他聊过，关于大流行对表演艺术，对表演艺术行业所产生的影响，嗯，他的剧院很幸运，
know they had the money to be able to withstand this, but a lot of these small community theaters are just, he said something like 99% of the actors and performing arts union in the United States are currently out of work or something like that. And yeah, I mean, this pandemic is definitely hurting some folks a lot more than it's hurting us. So I think that's a great point. I shouldn't say it doesn't impact us. Relatively speaking, it impacts us less. And I will say, like, neither of us have dependents. We don't
你知道的，他们有钱能够挺过这一关，但许多这样的小型社区剧院只是，他说美国演员工会和表演艺术工会中大约99%的演员目前失业了，诸如此类的话。是的，我的意思是，这场大流行绝对让一些人受到的伤害比我们大得多。所以我认为这是一个很好的观点。我不应该说它对我们没有影响。相对而言，它对我们的影响较小。而且我要说的是，我们两个都没有家属。我们没有
have kids. And I think, you know, there are a large number of people in technology that do have families and kids. And so I just, we're about to talk about the highlights of 2020 and sort of try and pull some positive things out. But I just, I don't want to do that without sort of acknowledging that 2020 has been a wreck of a year. And I'm very, very, very hopeful that 2021 will turn around. And yeah, so. Well, I actually, I think one of the highlights
孩子。我想，你知道，科技行业有大量的人确实有家庭和孩子。所以，我们即将讨论2020年的亮点，并试图从中找出一些积极的东西，但我只是，我不想在不承认2020年是糟糕的一年的情况下就直接开始。而且我非常、非常、非常希望2021年会有所转机。所以，是的。嗯，其实，我认为其中的一个亮点
for me of 2020 has been how – so I'm very involved in programming language standards. I chair the U.S. Standards Committee for Programming Language Standards, and I'm mostly – I'm most heavily involved with the C++ standard. I have a light involvement with the Fortran standard and a very late involvement with the C standard. And one thing that I've seen as a highlight of this year has been the resiliency that C, C++, and Fortran committees have shown in the face of this pandemic, we weren't really set up to be able to work remotely at the start of the year. You know, the way that all of these programming languages were evolved was we would meet a few times a year in person. And we do a lot of the work at those face-to-face meetings. And that might sound like, you know, in 2020, it may sound like in 2019,
对于我来说，2020年的一大亮点一直是——所以我非常参与编程语言标准的工作。我是美国编程语言标准委员会的主席，我主要——我最深入参与的是C++标准。我对Fortran标准有少许参与，对C标准有很晚的参与。我看到今年的一大亮点是，C、C++和Fortran委员会面对这场大流行病所表现出的韧性。在今年年初，我们其实并没有做好远程工作的准备。你知道，所有这些编程语言演变的方式是，我们每年会面几次进行面对面交流。我们在这些面对面的会议上完成了大量工作。这听起来可能，你知道，在2020年，听起来在2019年，
you know, that's a little bit dated. But you have to keep in mind that's the way we've been doing things for many years. And there is a value to to face-to-face interactions and I've been very impressed at how far we've been able to come in switching to working remotely in the middle of this pandemic and I'm very grateful to all the people, you know, not only the leadership, but also the, just the participants who have really stepped up in this time. Um, and, and I'm very proud of all the things that we were able to get done this year, despite the pandemic. Yeah, no, that's, uh, I think it's great to see, um, C++ and sort of older languages, you know, C, Fortran, C++, they all have long histories. And I think a lot of newer languages are used to sort of operating more on, you know, generally speaking, GitHub.
你知道，这有点过时了。但你必须记住，这是我们多年来一直做事的方式。面对面的互动是有价值的。我对我们在这场大流行中期转向远程工作所取得的进展印象深刻，我非常感谢所有人，你知道，不仅是领导层，还有那些在这个时期真正挺身而出的参与者们。嗯，并且，我为我们今年尽管有大流行却依然能够完成的所有事情感到非常自豪。是的，不，这，嗯，我认为看到C++和一些较古老的语言，你知道，C、Fortran、C++，它们都有着悠久的历史，这真的很棒。而且我认为许多较新的语言习惯于更倾向于在，你知道，总的来说，在GitHub上运作。
That's not how every new programming language evolves, but a lot of them do um and it's great to see like languages with older histories uh be able to adapt um and still make progress like it's it's going to be great to still get you know an update with c++ 23 and new things in our language in our library and that's awesome um well and one one of the things that I saw sort of a status update on this on Twitter last week that there's this new thing called FortranLaying.org in a related GitHub org, which is, it was an effort started about a year ago, I think actually just before the pandemic
并非每个新编程语言的演变都是这样的，但很多都是，而且很高兴看到具有悠久历史的语言能够适应，并且依然取得进展——能够继续获得带有C++ 23的更新，以及我们的语言和库中的新东西，这真的很棒，这太棒了。嗯，还有一件事，我上周在推特上看到关于这个的状态更新，有一个叫FortranLang.org的新东西，以及一个相关的GitHub组织，这是一个大约在一年前开始的项目，我想实际上就在大流行之前，
to sort of democratize the Fortran evolution process a little bit. You know, the Fortran has this international standards committee, but the idea here was, hey, let's create this forum and venue where Fortran users can propose ideas, can suggest what our priorities should be, et cetera. And I saw a retrospective on sort of all the good that had generated in the past year. And I was very impressed with that. You know, Fortran's a language that was created in the 1950s and has regularly released, you know, revisions since then. And it's not, you know, I think a lot of people maybe don't have the best opinion of Fortran, but I think a lot of those people maybe don't know what modern Fortran looks like and don't realize that it's not a dead language.
为了使Fortran的演变过程稍微民主化一点。你知道，Fortran有一个国际标准委员会，但这里的想法是，嘿，让我们创建一个论坛和平台，让Fortran用户可以提出想法，可以建议我们的优先级应该是什么，等等。我看到了过去一年它所产生的所有好处的回顾，我对此印象深刻。你知道，Fortran是一种在20世纪50年代创建的语言，并且从那时起定期发布修订版本。并且它不是，你知道，我想很多人对Fortran可能没有最好的看法，但我认为这些人中的许多人可能不知道现代Fortran是什么样的，也没有意识到它不是一门死去的语言。
It's a language that's constantly evolving, and it's still going strong. And, yeah, I think it's pretty cool to see all the great things that are coming out of this sort of democratization of the Fortran standardization process. Yeah, we'll definitely link this in the show notes. This is actually quite impressive. The top repos on the GitHub page for the Fortran programming language are FPM, the Fortran package manager, which I had no idea about, and then stdlib, so there's a Fortran standard library. Yeah, and it looks like they've got a double-digit number of contributors. And, you know, a lot of C++ people have been looking forward to modules for a number of years. You know, Fortran has had modules for, I don't know exactly how long,
它是一门不断演进的语言，而且依然充满活力。并且，是的，看到这种Fortran标准化过程的民主化所带来的所有伟大成果，我觉得这真的很酷。是的，我们肯定会在节目文稿中链接这个。这其实相当令人印象深刻。Fortran编程语言的GitHub页面上的顶级仓库是FPM，即Fortran包管理器，我对此一无所知，然后是stdlib，所以有一个Fortran标准库。是的，看起来他们有两位数的贡献者。而且，你知道，许多C++人员多年来一直在期待模块（modules）。你知道，Fortran拥有模块已经，我不知道具体有多久，
but definitely at least a couple of years before C++. I think it's been around since maybe Fortran 2008. But yeah, Fortran has a lot of, like modern Fortran has a lot of features that you might not expect. And there's another sort of exciting thing that has been going on this year, which is one of the things that our company NVIDIA works on is this project called Flang. And it's not quite sort of ready for its first release yet.
但绝对比C++早了至少好几年。我想它可能从Fortran 2008开始就有了。但是，是的，Fortran有很多，就像现代Fortran有很多你可能意想不到的功能。今年还有另一件令人兴奋的事情，那就是我们公司NVIDIA正在致力于的一个项目，叫做Flang。它还没完全准备好发布第一个版本。
But what Flang is, is it is a modern Fortran compiler written in the style of Clang. So it's meant to be modular. It's meant to be like a library. It's meant to be something that you can use for tooling, something that fits into the LLVM ecosystem. And it's written in modern C++17. Like this brand new Fortran compiler, which is going to be a part of the LLVM project, is written in modern C++17. And not only that, some of you have probably heard of MLIR, which is this new sort of high-level IR framework for LLVM.
但Flang是什么呢，它是一个模仿Clang风格编写的现代Fortran编译器。所以它的设计是模块化的。它旨在成为一个库。它旨在成为你可以用于工具开发的东西，一个融入LLVM生态系统的东西。它是用现代C++17编写的。就像这个全新的Fortran编译器，它将成为LLVM项目的一部分，是用现代C++17编写的。不仅如此，你们有些人可能听说过MLIR，这是LLVM的一种新的高级IR框架。
It's the sequel to LLVM, basically. It's like Chris Lattner's quasi-new project. Yeah, yeah. But it's not something that's in place of LLVM. What MLIR is meant to provide you is a way of building a high level intermediate representation that you can use. For example, you can use it to, with high fidelity, represent the structure of loops and to do things like loop optimizations that are a lot trickier to do in just, if the only
它基本上是LLVM的续集。它就像是Chris Lattner的准新项目。是的，是的。但它并不是用来取代LLVM的东西。MLIR旨在为你提供一种构建你可以使用的高级中间表示的方法。例如，你可以用它来高保真地表示循环的结构，并做一些事情，比如循环优化，如果你的程序的唯一表示只有LLVM IR，这些优化做起来会棘手得多。
representation of your program you have is LLVM IR. And one of the first major users of ML IR has been Fortran. Our flaying Fortran compilers all based around this,izations and vectorization that makes Fortran. Do you have any sense of why Fortran has, you know, you could arguably say it's been the most successful old language. Like, you know, it was created in the 50s and is typically quoted as being, you know, one of the first two languages alongside Lisp. And Lisp has also done incredibly well um but do you have a
而ML IR的首批主要用户之一就是Fortran。我们的flang Fortran编译器完全基于此，优化和向量化使Fortran得以实现。你知不知道为什么Fortran会，你知道，可以说它是最成功的古老语言。就像，你知道，它是在50年代创建的，通常被引为与Lisp并列的最早的两门语言之一。而且Lisp也做得非常成功，嗯，但是你知不知道
sense of why fortran you know there's many languages like kobol and apl that you know there was an article that will link in the show notes a year ago or so that said you know the top 10 dead languages that you've never heard of um you know small talk was on the list apl was on the list and you know you can leave your angry comments if you're a big fan of those languages, but you can't really say that Fortran has died. Do you have an idea of why that is, or did it do something right that the other languages did wrong, or do you know enough about it to... I got a theory. It's a very vague theory, but I got a theory just off the top of my head.
为什么Fortran，你知道的，有许多语言比如COBOL和APL，你知道，大约一年前有一篇文章我们会在节目文稿中链接，上面说，你知道你没听说过的十大死去的语言，小巧语（Smalltalk）在榜单上，APL在榜单上，并且，如果你是这些语言的超级粉丝，你可以留下你愤怒的评论，但你真的不能说Fortran已经消亡了。你知道这是为什么吗，还是它做对了某些事而其他语言做错了，或者你对它了解得足够多能……我有一个理论。这是一个非常模糊的理论，但我脑子里突然冒出了一个理论。
And my theory is that Fortran has always been very well positioned to capture an important industry and domain. Fortran's always been a really good language for numeric and scientific computing. And when Fortran was first created, it was in the 50s. And I think at the time, there was sort of roughly, let's say, two categories of computing. There was sort of business-oriented computing, the sort of things that languages like COBOL were designed and good for. Things that are, I think, similar to what we think of as like data analytics today. You know, COBOL is the language that you'd use to, you know, if you had some database of customers and you wanted to get some, generate some form letter for each of them or perform some query on your, you know, the list of all the customers that you had. Whereas Fortran was always sort of a language for these American scientific computing.
我的理论是，Fortran一直处于非常有利的位置，能够占领一个重要的行业和领域。Fortran一直是一门非常好的用于数值和科学计算的语言。当Fortran最初被创建时，是在50年代。我想当时大致有，比方说，两类计算。一类是面向商业的计算，就像COBOL这类语言为其设计且擅长的那些。这些事情，我认为类似于我们今天所想的数据分析。你知道，COBOL是这样一种语言，如果你有一些客户数据库，并且你想为他们每个人生成某种标准信件，或者对你拥有的所有客户名单执行某种查询，你就会使用它。而Fortran一直是一种用于这些美国科学计算的语言。
And that's always been an important use case and application. And it's always been used in this space where the priority has been on the science, where Fortran's always been a tool that's been used. You know, when you're a computational scientist, you're really a scientist first and a programmer second. And so I think there may have been more of a desire within the numerics and scientific computing community to stick with and evolve the tool that they knew instead of creating a new tool. Whereas somebody who's a computer programmer first might have a greater interest in switching to a new language. And that sort of, that user base of numeric and scientific computing has always been a constant since, you know since the start of computing um it's evolved a bit over the years
这始终是一个重要的用例和应用。它一直被用于这个以科学为优先级的领域，Fortran一直是一种被使用的工具。当你是一个计算科学家时，你实际上首先是一个科学家，其次才是一个程序员。所以我认为在数值和科学计算社区内，可能更倾向于坚持并演进他们所熟知的工具，而不是创建一个新工具。而那些首先是计算机程序员的人可能会对转向一种新语言有更大的兴趣。并且这种，数值和科学计算的用户群自计算开始以来一直是一个常量，你知道，自从计算开始以来，它这些年来略有演变，
but i think that's a large chunk of it i also think that that fortran as a language um is quite well designed it has very powerful built-in arrays, and not just one-dimensional arrays, but multi-dimensional arrays, and then expressions and operations on those arrays. It's very well-suited for the domains where it is used, scientific computing, simulation, et cetera. It's a really good fit. Um, and if you're a domain scientist, it's a fairly natural language to go and learn.
但我认为这占了很大一部分。我也认为Fortran作为一门语言，设计得相当好。它拥有非常强大的内置数组，不仅是一维数组，还有多维数组，以及对这些数组的表达式和操作。它非常适合它所使用的领域，如科学计算、模拟等。这是一个非常契合的组合。而且，如果你是一个领域科学家，去学习并掌握它是一门相当自然的语言。
Um, but, uh, yeah, that's, I mean, we, we could do a whole episode on that, I'm sure. And, and learn more about that. Um, out of, out of languages of that era, the one in which I'm really the expert is more COBOL, which is still around, but not in the same way that Fortran is. Yeah, it's interesting to think about. Fortran is not a DSL. It's not a domain-specific language.
但是，嗯，是的，我的意思是，我们完全可以围绕这个做一个完整的节目，我确信。并且对此了解更多。嗯，在那个时代的语言中，我真正算得上专家的那个更偏向COBOL，它依然存在，但并非以Fortran的那种方式存在。是的，这很有趣。Fortran不是一个DSL（领域特定语言）。它不是一个领域特定语言。
Yet, it is like a domain targeted language. Like it is, like you said, it's it's specifically designed with scientific compute in mind. And I'm not sure really, you can say that about many programming languages, like, so that that is, that's very interesting, like that response. And it's sort of, it makes sense in my head that a domain targeted language, which many languages are not, like, and that's another thing, is I guess like sort of Erlang is another language that has, to a certain extent, lived on in the form of Elixir.
然而它确实像是一种面向特定领域的语言。就像你说的，它是专为科学计算而设计的。我不确定你是否真的能对许多编程语言这样说，所以，这非常有趣，那种回应。在我脑海里这说得通，一个面向特定领域的语言，而许多语言并非如此，这也是另一回事，我想就像Erlang是另一种在某种程度上以Elixir形式延续下来的语言。
And I believe many telecom companies that require extremely fault-tolerant, scalable systems, they're still built in Erlang. If I'm not mistaken, like WhatsApp, which got acquired for, what, $19 billion? It was the company with the highest per-employee. I think they had 30 employees or 55 employees or something. And the per-employee price was in the hundreds of millions of dollars. They famously used Erlang to build their infrastructure. And Erlang, you could say, is also like a domain targeted, like they target,
我相信许多需要极度容错、可扩展系统的电信公司，仍然是用Erlang构建的。如果我没记错的话，比如WhatsApp，它被以多少，190亿美元的价格收购了？它是每位员工价值最高的公司。我想他们有30名员工或55名员工左右。每位员工的价格高达数亿美元。他们出名地使用Erlang来构建他们的基础架构。并且Erlang，你也可以说它就像是一个面向特定领域的，就像他们面向的是，
although can you call fault tolerant systems and like scalable systems like that, a domain, maybe not. But like, arguably, you can even extend that to C++, you know, it sort of gets less away from the domain and more for use case, but like, you know, C++ and C, those languages are, you know, where you can't have latency, you know, you know, people say, oh, garbage collection is the future. I'm not ever going to use a language that doesn't have GC. Yet there are certain applications where you can't, you can't have that. It's not acceptable. You know, for instance, Plus you need a language to write the GC in. Yeah. You know, if I'm listening to a song, I don't want, it's so irritating if it skips,
虽然你能把容错系统和像那样的可扩展系统称为一个领域吗，也许不能。但是，可以说，你甚至可以将其扩展到C++，你知道，它稍微脱离了领域，更多地指向用例，但是就像，你知道，C++和C，那些语言是，你知道，在不能有延迟的地方，你知道，人们说，哦，垃圾回收（GC）是未来。我绝不会使用没有GC的语言。然而某些应用场景下你不能，你不能有那个。那是不可接受的。你知道，例如，加上你需要一种语言来编写GC。是的。你知道，如果我在听一首歌，我不要，如果它卡顿了会非常烦人，
you know, at some point it's, it's, it's just like any, anybody that's been listening to a song where it's sort of, it's, it's awful. So you're not going to write, you're not going to write some, some audio program in, in some GC language that has a risk of that. But anyways, it's, a lot, a lot of the early programming languages were more targeted at specific use cases you know cobalt was a language that was created for a specific domain fortran was a language that was created for a specific domain a lot of languages that were created after that were not targeted at a specific and when I say domain here I don't mean like systems programming or like back-end versus like front-end I mean like a um uh an an actual end user application
你知道，在某些时候，它，它，它就像任何听过一首歌并遇到卡顿的人一样，那太糟糕了。所以你不会用某种有这种风险的带有GC的语言去编写某些音频程序。但无论如何，很多早期的编程语言更多地是针对特定的用例，你知道COBOL是一种为特定领域创建的语言，Fortran是一种为特定领域创建的语言，之后创建的许多语言并没有针对特定的，当我这里说“领域”时，我并不是指系统编程或后端对前端，我的意思是，一个，嗯，一个真正的最终用户应用程序
you know scientific computing or business computing etc um I think a lot of languages that were created after that, you know, first set in the 50s and 60s were more general purpose languages, or they were targeted, you know, at sort of how high or low level they were going to be, but they weren't aimed at suiting the needs of a particular domain. And so I think that's probably a good chunk of why languages like Fortran have such longevity, because it was built from the ground up to suit a particular need, and there weren't a lot of alternatives. The only thing that I think has really come close to supplanting fortran has only really started being
你知道的，比如科学计算或商业计算等，嗯，我认为之后创建的很多语言，你知道，在50年代和60年代首次确立的那些之后，更多的是通用语言，或者它们的目标，你知道，取决于它们的高低级程度，但它们的目的是为了迎合特定领域的某个需求。所以我觉得这也是为什么像Fortran这样的语言能有如此长生命周期的很大一部分原因，因为它从头到当时就是为了满足特定需求而构建的，而且当时也没有太多替代品。我唯一觉得真正接近取代Fortran的语言，其实才刚刚开始
supplanted by other languages in the past 10 20 years that is yeah it's it's definitely food for thought because another thing about python that people don't realize, like Python is viewed as sort of a newer language, like alongside, you know, Rust and Swift and Elm, etc. But Python is actually an older language. It was created around the same time C++ was back in the 90s. You know, C++ has a longer history from before the 90s. Um, and a lot of certain talks in this, in the Python community, um, highlight that really the, the, you know, the curve and the hockey stick, you know, of, of the popularity of Python has been driven by, um, the, the data science and sort of, uh, machine learning and, um, like the, the balloon and the ecosystem of libraries that are NumPy and pandas.
在过去10到20年里被其他语言取代，是的，这确实很耐人寻味，因为关于Python还有一点是人们没有意识到的，比如Python被视为一种较新的语言，就像Rust、Swift和Elm等一样。但实际上Python是一种更古老的语言。它创建的时间大约和C++在90年代差不多。你知道的，C++在90年代之前还有更长的历史。嗯，这个社区里的一些演讲，嗯，强调说，实际上，Python流行度的那条曲线和曲棍球杆曲线，是由数据科学、机器学习以及NumPy和pandas等库的生态系统的繁荣所推动的。
That has really, but Python wasn't designed from the ground up for that, right? It was not. Yeah. But so that, that's, that's one of the, the creator,
确实如此，但Python最初并不是为了这个而从头设计的，对吧？确实不是。是的。不过，这也是，那创造者之一，
Wes McKinney of pandas has claimed in his talk and has showed sort of numbers for that, you know, Python, it was, it was, you know, a language that was popular enough,
pandas的作者Wes McKinney在他的演讲中曾声称并展示了一些数据，你知道，Python，它曾经是一种足够受欢迎的语言，
but it's, it was not, you know, in the top five or, you know, ranked as number one or number two on a lot of these charts. And if you look at sort of the numbers and the adoption of certain libraries, uh, you could argue that, uh, you know, a large, uh, contributor to the, you know, extreme popularity of Python has been sort of the focus on, uh, like you were saying, the, the scientific compute, the scientific compute and NumPy and Pandas and Scikit-learn
但它并没有，你知道的，排在许多这类排行榜的前五名，或者排在第一或第二位。如果你看一下某些库的数据和采用率，嗯，你可以认为，嗯，Python之所以能获得极高的知名度，很大一部分贡献来自于对特定领域的专注，就像你刚才说的，科学计算、科学计算以及NumPy、Pandas和Scikit-learn
and the whole ecosystem of libraries that are now available in Python for people working in those domains. So it's interesting to think that trying to design a language, potentially a more successful trajectory, is to choose a target domain and focus on that and then really like develop those, the libraries and the ecosystem around that domain instead of trying to become like a general purpose language that's used for everything.
以及现在Python中可供这些领域人员使用的整个库生态系统。所以这就很有意思，尝试设计一门语言时，一条可能更成功的轨迹是选择一个目标领域并专注于此，然后真正围绕这个领域去开发那些库和生态系统，而不是试图成为一种无所不包的通用语言。
Yeah. And I mean, if you're trying to design a general purpose language, you know, like, let's say that you and I were building a new programming language that, that wasn't targeting a particular domain. In our, like the first few things we would do, like, you know, we'd look at, you know, what should we be working on? What should we be focusing? What should our priorities be? We wouldn't be prioritizing features that were specifically only going to enable this one domain of users.
是的。我的意思是，如果你试图设计一种通用语言，你知道，比方说你和我正在构建一种新的编程语言，它不是针对特定领域的。在我们的工作中，最开始要做的事情之一，你知道，我们会去研究，你知道，我们应该从事什么？我们应该专注于什么？我们的优先级应该是什么？我们就不会去优先考虑那些专门只服务于这一个领域用户的特性。
We'd be like, nah, we got to, that's like a version five feature. We got to focus on these other things first. And so what that means is that for a general purpose language, like something like Python, yes, eventually it can grow to a scale where it has a rich enough ecosystem, a rich enough set of features that a dedicated ecosystem pops up within the wider Python ecosystem for that particular use case. But that requires a greater scale, a greater maturity. Whereas if you go in from the start and you say, our language is going to focus on doing this thing well, then that lets you focus better. And I think really, I think that's been a large part of what's made Fortran successful. And, you know, again, to go back to that, you know, the mindset
我们会觉得，不，我们必须……那就像是第五版的特性。我们首先得专注于其他事情。这意味着，对于通用语言，比如像 Python 这样的语言，是的，最终它可以发展到一定规模，拥有足够丰富的生态系统、足够丰富的特性集，从而在更广泛的 Python 生态系统中为特定用例涌现出一个专属的生态系统。但这需要更大的规模、更高的成熟度。而如果你从一开始就切入，说我们的语言将专注于把这件事做好，那么这能让你更好地聚焦。我认为，实际上，这也是 Fortran 成功的大部分原因。而且，再次回到那种心态
in the 50s, I think when languages like Fortran and COBOL were created, there wasn't yet a notion of this general purpose programmer. There were the notion of these people who needed to use these tools in their work. And in certain domains, you know, that sort of remained true to this day. If you're a computational scientist, your priority is the, you know, the science and the language is just a tool. And that's something that's sort of built into,
在 50 年代，我认为当 Fortran 和 COBOL 这样的语言被创造出来时，还没有“通用程序员”这个概念。当时的概念是那些需要在工作中使用的工具的人。在某些领域，你知道，这种情直到今天依然存在。如果你是一个计算科学家，你的首要任务是科学，而语言只是一个工具。这种理念已经内化于
into a language like Fortran. So we, we took the risk and it has sort of turned into a Fortran episode. Fortran will definitely have to go on the title of this episode. And that is where we will end part one of our 2020 retro episode thanks for listening tune in next week for part two and happy new year There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
像 Fortran 这样的语言中。所以我们承担了风险，结果这变成了一期关于 Fortran 的节目。Fortran 绝对得成为这期节目的标题。我们的 2020 回顾节目第一部分就到这里结束了，感谢收听，下周请继续收听第二部分，新年快乐！本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。